[Applause]
[Music]
no
[Music]
okay okay okay so uh that may not have
been the answer
that people were expecting from me and i
suspect that
my reasons for having that answer may
not be obvious so let me explain in my
rambling fashion in many ways this is
going to serve as something of a
companion piece to the videos i did
earlier about taking on uh in the works
of problematic creators and also
separating the artists from the art
and my conclusion here is going to
pretty much be along the same lines as
that second one
um so a quick reminder i don't believe
you actually can
or should fully separate the artist from
the art and check the video
for a refresher of why if you need to
now the thing is in those two videos i
made
the very deliberate choice to focus on
works
that had a clear single or primary
creative force
that's why i mostly talked about authors
and novels because
while there are some other people
involved in those things editors cover
artists
etc it ultimately comes down to just one
person for the sake of simplicity in
those videos i'd opted to not
deal with more collaborative art forms
like film tv shows or video games
where the sheer volume of people
involved make it
a lot more likely that there's going to
be a problematic contributor
somewhere in the mix so
that collaborative art form is what
we're going to be tackling today
by taking a look at the involvement of
rosario dawson
and gina carano in the disney plus tv
show
the mandalorian which recently dropped
the trailer for its second season
so i'm gonna try to bring you up to
speed quickly
on this because actually despite the
title and the thumbnail
i don't really want to dwell on the
specifics of these two people
and would much rather have a broader
discussion
but i still need a leaping off point so
let's add some context now late last
year
rosario dawson had very troubling
allegations
leveled against her and members of her
family by a trans man
who'd been working for them there were
no criminal charges but a civil suit is
still currently working its way through
the court system
now dawson herself probably wisely
has not really spoken publicly about any
of this which means that it's largely
lapsed out of the news cycle
but for those of us who are members of
the
trans or lgbtq plus community it's put
something of a shadow of discomfort
over her casting as fan favorite
character ahsoka
in the new season now gina carano was
already a cast member
in season one and what happened with her
it's honestly kind of stupid it's one of
those things where hyperbolic reactions
from her
and others escalated what shouldn't have
been a very big deal
but in brief she made a somewhat
tone-deaf
joke about the habits of trans people
and trans allies
of putting their pronouns in their bios
and it just
spiraled from there if you want a full
breakdown jesse gender did a great video
going all
over all of this in way more detail and
if you really want to know the full
detail of everything that's gone on i
recommend checking that out
but what that means is that there are
now two cast members in the mandalorian
who
are giving those who care about trans
rights and causes
reason for pause so in the wake of this
i've seen calls for their firing to
start to pop up which
to be clear won't happen because the
thing's largely already been
shot and also conversations asking the
question that i put in the title
should they be fired and as i said at
the beginning my
answer personally to that is no
now my purpose
here is not going to be to try and make
the case for why
you should come to the same conclusion
that i have
but rather i just want to explain my own
thought process and approach to all this
because
i feel like the reason i got here isn't
the reason
i'm seeing other people arriving at the
same conclusion and
frankly the journey you take to your
answer matters
now to my memory i've
never called for the firing or removal
of an actor from a film or a tv show
i've bemoaned casting choices and
performances
there's no question about that but
that's not what we're talking about here
because this isn't a case of they didn't
do a good job in the part
this is a conversation completely
separate
from the quality of their work and i
don't
think calling for removals is something
i'm ever
really gonna do either because
well to ask for that is a way to duck
out of having to make
an uncomfortable choice and i don't
think it's healthy
to duck out on those things what i mean
by that is
this isn't about cancel culture at least
it isn't for me
no for me the problem is that people
want to buy or watch the things they
want with as few
complicating factors as possible and
well honestly i i get that if there's a
franchise you love
or a movie or video game you've been
looking forward to especially if you've
been looking forward to it for a long
time
suddenly if there's a person involved
who makes you
uncomfortable by belief or alleged
action
that can take the wind out of your
enthusiasm
and your enjoyment it can spoil the fun
it's why many hardcore fans have a
tendency to shoot the messenger
whenever these things get talked about i
mean you can look at how much hate gets
thrown at jim sterling every time he
brings up
the verifiable fact that most big budget
video game developers
exploit and abuse their workforce
people don't want to know because they
just want to enjoy the things they want
and to my way of thinking calling for
the removal of an actor
comes from a similar place granted with
the
extra step of actually asking somebody
to remove the complication
for you rather than just deliberately
deciding to
ignore it and pretend like it's not
there
but when you ask for these people to be
fired you're asking
for somebody to make it easy for you to
just enjoy the thing
because if the person in question wasn't
there you wouldn't have to think about
it anymore
and this applies across the board i
don't care what your beliefs are i
guarantee you
there is or has been a property that you
liked
or were excited for that involved at
least one person
you wish it didn't because that person
or their beliefs
made you uncomfortable for whatever
reason
wouldn't it just be easier if they
weren't there
well yeah but i've said before
that's just not the world we live in
honestly asking these people to be fired
isn't all that far removed from the
people who wanted disney to remake the
last jedi
and change all the plot elements they
didn't like it's coming
from that same place of you should make
it what
i want it to be so no
i don't think they should be fired
but i also now have no plans to watch
the second season of
the mandalorian which
is the kind of choice that sucks to make
it's the choice that you try to avoid
by asking them to be fired it's giving
up something
that might have brought you joy in that
sucks believe me i know this stuff sucks
being an adult dealing with the
complicated mess that is the modern
world
really [ __ ] sucks
but you still have to do it it's still
your responsibility to make the choice
to either support the work or not it's
not the responsibility
of the team creating it to make that
easier for you
and also let me be clear this isn't me
saying
vote with your wallet start a boycott
because it doesn't take much digging to
very quickly realize that boycotts they
don't work
the vast majority of people who wanted
the thing still want the thing and will
still
get the thing so i'm not choosing to
bail on the second season of the show
in some misguided attempt to send disney
a message
i'm doing it for me i'm not comfortable
supporting this show with this cast
right now and maybe i'll feel different
at some point in the future in the years
to come but right now
i'm uncomfortable and it's up to me
to do what's best for my own comfort and
well-being
it's not up to disney to take care of it
for me
i hope you've been able to follow me on
this trip through my mind
and my thought processes and i
i just want you to understand if you
choose to watch the second season of the
show i'm not judging you
if you look at what's going on and
decide that you're okay with watching it
that's fine and i have no business
telling you otherwise
if you still want to watch it then watch
it
if you want to bail bail just don't go
demanding other people
make the world less complicated for you
because that's not how
anything works now this particular video
has no sponsor so instead i'm going to
quickly plug the kickstarter for my
fantasy novel which
at time of recording is coming
tantalizingly close to hitting a stretch
goal
that would fund a professionally
recorded
audiobook version which would then be
made available to backers
at every level so maybe give that a look
of course i've also got a patreon which
is what's currently paying my bills and
keeping the lights on
and there's the usual stuff like share
subscribe
merch links social media links etc down
in the description
i hope if you have thoughts that you'll
leave a comment
because comments on these kinds of
videos have a tendency to spur on new
topics of discussion for
me but you also don't have to do
any of this i mean i'd appreciate it but
at the end of the day you are the
council
i'm just running the meetings and until
next time this council
is adjourned
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
um
[Music]
foreign